it's September 11th so we commemorate
9/11 we also talk about Hillary Clinton
who just can't let go
plus I'm headed to Berkeley and
apparently it's just like a hurricane or
something I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show all righty so I am
ready to give you the update on Berkeley
because it is hilarious hilarious let me
tell you and I will tell you all of the
things about that I'll also give you
some notes on 9/11 plus I want to talk
about Hillary Clinton's in an interview
Steve Bennett in an interview so a lot
to get to today but before we do any of
that first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at my Patriot supply
so let's say that you're watching TV and
you saw that there are some natural
disasters on the TV and you thought
yourself hmm I wonder what those people
would do if they were stuck in their
house without access to let's say a
grocery store or electricity what would
they do the answer is if they had my
Patriot supply they'd be in good shape
you would be - okay anywhere you live in
the country there are natural disasters
that can hit you there's also the
possibility of course that Kim jong-un
decides to fire a nuclear-tipped missile
at the west coast of the United States
in which case you would be wise to have
something in your house that you can eat
so you don't have to wander outside and
be turned into a frog human so that is
why it is necessary to go over to my
Patriot supply right now
and get some supplies okay get their
survival food supply for just $99 it
includes a hundred and two servings of
breakfast lunch and dinner for less than
a dollar per serving order now eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen that's eight eight eight eight
oh three fourteen thirteen or online and
prepare with been calm that's prepare
with been calm my Patriot supply they
believe in old-fashioned values and you
can join me in their mission to build a
more prepared and self-reliant country
eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen prepare
with been calm it's prepared with been
calm again for 99 bucks you're making
sure your family is safe this seems like
a no-brainer to me prepare with Ben calm
you look at the disasters right now
there's no question you should be
prepared prepare with Ben calm okay so
here is the update on Brookley so at
Berkeley
okay Berkeley has decided that I am I'm
a real threat okay this is a headline
from the LA Times quote Berkeley braces
for right-wing talk-show host Ben
Shapiro's visit braces for it like it's
a hurricane like oh my god I'm coming
and I'm talking on Thursday what are
they ever going to do now the reason
they're really
upset is because the antifa has
threatened violence over the weekend we
saw an Tifa rioting in Portland again
this time attacking police officers I
can safely say it's all my fault
I guess or something okay the fact is
that Berkeley is I would say going above
and beyond in terms of its security
Garrity
said we couldn't bring a thousand people
because they were afraid people were
gonna go in the upper deck of the
stadium and start throwing chairs down
on people which is just totally insane
then they've apparently created a
security perimeter they're creating a
hard security perimeter when I go on
Thursday that means that they're going
to have police cordons basically around
six buildings they've shut down the
building's completely so people have to
have classes and other buildings listen
this is not my fault folks it's not
something I wanted I just would like to
be able to go there and talk about the
things that I talked about and I was
unaware that I was such a controversial
figure I mean I sort of knew but I
didn't realize it was to this extent but
it's really because of Berkeley but
don't worry it's really cuz of me
according to the LA Times it's because
Berkeley is bracing for me they're not
bracing for an tifa's reaction to a
conservative visiting no they're bracing
for me if only I didn't descend with my
130 mile per hour winds on Berkeley then
they wouldn't have to worry about this
so much Berkeley is also freaking out
because they've also suggested that they
want to provide counseling for students
who are hurt by my words seriously this
is what they're actually saying they
want counseling so according to Newsweek
okay a head of a talk from conservative
political commentator ben shapiro at UC
berkeley a letter has been sent by the
university to students faculty and staff
stating that counseling services will be
made available to those who quote feel
threatened or harassed by certain
speakers what we are deeply concerned
about the impact some speakers may have
on individual sense of safety and
belonging
hey I'll agree with this much if you
feel so insulted by my speech that you
feel that your safety has been assaulted
you definitely need mental help if you
really feel that way then you can
certainly use some counseling because
you're a sad sack pathetic piece of crap
like seriously if this is what you worry
about all day is that I'm gonna come to
your University and I'm gonna say oh
conservative things no God forbid
no and you need counseling then let me
suggest that you actually do need
counseling I do love what the left does
here that they so overstep their
boundaries it's insane and Tifa is
suggesting that I am a white supremacist
now which is hysterically funny refused
says I'm a fascist thug and a white
supremacist which is really amusing
considering I was literally the number
one recipient of hatred from the
alt-right on Twitter last year according
to the anti-defamation league so that's
pretty awesome refused fascism issued a
statement clearing campuses must become
fascist free zones how through fascism
of course we have to make sure that no
one can get on campus that's how you
make sure it's a fascist free zone by
establishing your own fascist zone
that's obviously wid that you have to do
this so you know we're all prepped we're
ready to go
we are coming it should be interesting
the tickets sold out in 45 minutes we're
still trying to figure out how to deal
with the situation the eventualities
we're a bunch of antifoam members come
in the stadium into the into the venue
and then get up and leave and leave a
bunch of empty seats can people come in
after that we're working that out with
young America's Foundation so you can
contact them at young America's
Foundation at yah org but we are coming
and I will say that I think this whole
thing is wildly overblown and I'm not
sure whether to be flattered or insulted
it's it's pretty incredible actually
okay
in other news obviously it's pretty
somber anniversary today's the 16th
anniversary of 9/11 amazing how fast
time moves and remember that you know
everybody has their where were you when
9/11 happened story for me I was
let's see 17 years old and my dad and I
were actually supposed to go golfing
that morning and we dropped off my
sister's at school and as we pulled into
the parking lot one of the security
guards came running out and said that
planes had hit the World Trade Centers
and they had collapsed and we rushed it
inside the school and I remember that
the school which is an Orthodox Jewish
day school had told all the students
there was gonna be extra security they
did not in fact have extra security my
father and I standing there with golf
clubs were actually the extra security
so that was not probably planned but
obviously a horrific horrific day and
everybody remembers the images so it
gives you a pit in your stomach if
you're not old enough to remember if
you're one of my younger listeners then
you should go back and watch the tape
because it's important to know what
happened in our country on September
11th 2001 and it's important to remember
because there are certain lessons that
we learned after 9/11 that I think we
have sort of been in the process of
unlearning all of history tends to be a
process of learning lessons and then
forgetting them as fast as possible so
that you can repeat the history again so
I want to go through a couple of lessons
I think that it is worth remembering
from 9/11 so that we don't repeat 9/11
again even though I think that you know
that's the chances that there will be
another major
first attack sometime in the next ten
years I think I'm pretty high and I
don't just mean you know truck style
attacks from Isis I mean like an actual
spectacular attack that takes out
thousands of people and I'm not saying
that obviously I'm saying that with
tremendous with tremendous hope that I'm
wrong but it seems to me that the more
we go down this road of forgetting what
we learned on 9/11 the more we're
getting closer to that so number one
global retreat is not a strategy if you
remember the Clinton era
you remember that Clinton's basic
foreign policy strategy was retreat from
the world except when he did sort of
these pinprick strikes in particular
areas sometimes we'd intervene on
humanitarian grounds but we never
intervened with regard to preserving our
own security we never took preemptive
strikes to preserve preserve our own
security and bin Laden noticed in 1998
he bombs the American embassies in Kenya
and Tanzania that sovereign American
territory and the United States
basically did nothing when bin Laden
bombed the USS Cole the United States
did basically nothing and bin Laden I
mean this is in his writings said he
thought that we were a paper tiger at
that point it was only because of George
W Bush really like a George W Bush gets
a very bad historical rap but if you
talk to the people at al-qaeda from
al-qaeda they openly acknowledge that
they were not expecting the kind of
response that received from george w
bush they've prepared a second wave of
attacks and because bush was so
aggressive had finished that so james
mitchell who is the man who questioned
al-qaeda mastermind Khalid Sheikh
Mohammed who's the planner of 9/11 Qasim
said quote how was I supposed to know
that cowboy George Bush would announce
that he wanted us dead or alive and then
invade Afghanistan to hunt us down
according to Mitchell Qasim explained
that if the US had treated 9/11 like a
law enforcement matter he would have had
time to launch a second wave of attacks
but now it seems like we are very
reticent about pre-emptive attacks it
seems like we are reticent about looking
at the threats that face us I am
fighting Isis now which is great but
what about the next threat what about
Iran what about Hezbollah doesn't mean
that we have to take out the regime and
Iran does mean we have to go to war with
them but the fact is that unless we are
willing to consider measures to stamp
out terrorist groups across the planet
we are setting ourselves up for a fall
okay second lesson that we should have
learned on 9/11 money and friendliness
do not buy off Islamist there's this
weird idea from both the Ron Paul right
and from the Barack Obama left that if
we just give enough money if we just
show the Muslim world that
caring and wonderful that we will be
left alone by terrorists this is
absolute nonsense there's not an
argument by the way for being mean to
Muslims worldwide it's not an argument
for not having relationships with
countries like Saudi Arabia where we
have an actual intelligence relationship
it is an argument suggesting that if we
think that's enough if we think that
being friendly that being a human rights
proactive that this is going to be
enough to prevent terrorism we are
wildly mistaken and stupid the fact is
for a decade the Clinton administration
reached out to the Palestinian
government for example with cash with
concessions from the Israelis and you
remember the tape you do you remember
the tape on 9/11 of Palestinians handing
out candy in the streets to their
children as the towers fell
we were pretty humanitarian toward the
Muslim world in the 1990s right we saved
a bunch of Bosnian and and Croatian
Muslims in former Yugoslavia we
prevented the invasion of Kuwait by
Saddam Hussein we gave tons of money in
foreign aid to various Muslim countries
around the world in an attempt to
prevent humanitarian catastrophes we we
sacrificed American soldiers in far-off
places like Somalia just because we
didn't want to see the disaster of
Muslims dying for no reason
we did all of these things and that
obviously was not enough to turn off the
terrorists this is not to say we
shouldn't have done any of those things
what it is to say is that if you think
that that in and of itself is gonna buy
off terrorists you are sadly mistaken
the Obama administration took to heart
this idea that's why they back the
so-called Arab Spring oh if we backed
amok recei in Muslim places then
certainly these people will turn out to
be pro America not the way that it works
okay third lesson we should have learned
on 9/11 this is one I think President
Trump did take to heart that is
immigration matters okay immigration
matters 59 the nineteen hijackers were
Saudi all of them were here on visas all
of them were here on visas one was on a
student visa the other were here on
travel visas or business visas and
virtually all of them I believe
overstayed their visas not student visas
but other visas you know President Trump
has focused laser-like on a couple of
different areas of immigration he's
focused on deportation of people who
crossed the border illegally on the
southern border illegally he's focused
on building a border wall he's focused
on travel bans from seven specific
Muslim countries but what he has not
focused on so much is how we deport
people who are overstaying their visas
illegally okay half of all illegal
immigration in the country forty to 50
percent
is people who are overstaying their
visas illegally we left them in the
country and then we let them wander
around and we don't check up on them the
fact is that the government ought to be
deeply concerned about people who are
entering the country from Islamist rich
areas of the world no question but we
also should be careful about the people
who are already here we should be
checking up on them that's something
that I hope the Sessions DOJ does in the
fourth point that we recognized on 9/11
that we need to recap here is that major
terrorist attacks do require sponsor
states if you look at terror in Western
Europe in the United States what you
will see is that there was a giant spike
obviously in terror deaths in 2001 there
are a few more terror deaths in 2002 and
then you see a pretty big gap in terms
of terror against Americans and Western
Europeans from about 2003 2002 2003 all
the way until about 2010 2011 what
happened during that period well the
invasion of Afghanistan the invasion of
Iraq everybody hates the invasion of
Iraq the fact is major terrorist attacks
war 4 stalled because we were fighting
terrorists over there and we weren't
fighting them over here the minute that
Isis began to regain territory that gave
them the capacity to sponsor terror
attacks all over the world in a way they
had not been able to before
al-qaeda required a terrorist safe haven
in Afghanistan it's one of the reasons
why I think President Trump is correct
not to give up on the war in Afghanistan
I think that simply surrendering it back
to the Taliban is a recipe for another
state-sponsored terrorist attack this is
why the Iran deal is so devastating you
have a major wealthy power in Iran that
is willing to sponsor terror groups all
over the planet state sponsors of terror
can do things that simple terrorist
groups cannot you're always going to
have what they call lone-wolf terrorism
or small-cell terrorism that's not quite
the same thing as these major
spectacular terrorist attacks killing
hundreds of people that requires a base
like Isis to train people provide them
services provide them guns provide them
ammo provide them bombs provide them all
the things they need
finally final point on 9/11 and then
I'll move on to Hillary Clinton here
America has real enemies we're so busy
in the United States tearing each other
apart were the freest most wealthy power
in the history of the world and that
means that we tend to look at each other
and say well look al Qaeda isn't really
a threat to us Isis isn't a threat to us
it's not an existential threat anyway
Obama used to say this all the time he
used to say that this isn't an
existential threat ok it's not just the
government's job to protect you from
existential threats it is also the
being murdered in your bed it doesn't
have to
be an existential threat for it to be an
existential threat for you 9/11 was done
an existential threat to the United
States it was an existential threat to
the 3,000 Americans were murdered on
9/11 it is the government's job to
protect us from those things and when
people say things like well how many
soldiers died in order to protect us
from the next one number one we don't
know how many people were saved by that
we don't know the counterfactual and
number two it is very different to use
our military people who have volunteered
for our military go to fight the bad
guys that's why they join up and it is a
it is sort of a slander on their
patriotism to suggest they join the
military just for the benefits but they
don't join up in order to fight the bad
guys the vast majority of people I've
talked to in the military they joined up
to fight the bad guys and so long as the
government is deploying them properly
and they are more than happy to go and
kill the bad guys it's their job it's
what they're here to do okay so before I
go any further I'm gonna talk about
Hillary and Steve bannon's in an
interview on 60 minutes that's getting a
lot of play before I do any of that
first I want to ask you have you taken
any of your extra money and started
investing in real estate this is
something you absolutely should be doing
I always talk about diversification of
assets I always talk about you should
have some money in gold and silver you
should have some money in the stock
market and you should certainly be
looking at some other investments that
can have a high upside that can have a
high upside game because that's how
you're gonna make your real money you
take some of your money you invest it in
slow growth stocks you take some in
bonds put some in gold and then you take
some one you put it in some sort of high
net worth high ROI possibilities and
that is what Realty shares is for it's
not an offering of securities private
investments are highly illiquid and
risky and are not suitable for all
investors past performance is not
indicative of future results securities
offered to accredited investors through
north capital private securities member
finra s ipeec but right now if you have
$5,000 and you qualify then you can
invest in real estate you don't have to
take a hundred thousand dollars and
plunk it down on an apartment building
you can diversify this way you don't
have to be a billionaire in order to get
in on the real estate market that's
re-al t-y shares calm again here's the
way that it works you go to the website
they have a bunch of investments that
they have vetted and looked at and then
they allow you the capacity to invest in
$5,000 increments in these particular
properties you can it's free to sign up
and browse the investments getting set
up takes just a few minutes then you can
manage and invest straight from your
phone or computer through their simple
secure online process I'll
five grams make an investment there are
no hidden fees if you make $200,000 a
year you may qualify again find out at
realty shares comm slash pen that's
realty shares comm slash pen right now
they have a special offer just for my
listeners go today to realty shares comm
slash pen for a hundred bucks toward
your first investment again that's
realty shares comm slash pen for $100
toward your first investment that's re
alt why shares comm slash Ben for a
hundred bucks toward your first
investment that's Realty shares comm
slash Ben that also lets them know that
we sent you okay so in in more in in
less solemn political news Hillary
Clinton did one of her first big
interviews on her new book what happened
and the answer is you did Hillary a lot
of people saying Trump happened Hillary
happened to Hillary hey this is one
thing I did get right during the
election cycle I asked myself during the
election cycle is this thing a
referendum on Trump or is this thing a
referendum on Hillary Clinton and I said
over and over and over again this is a
referendum on Hillary Clinton it is not
a referendum on Trump Hillary Clinton is
the third term for Obama you looked at
her poll numbers she was bouncing around
between 39 and 50% Trump was very stable
at between 41 and 44 percent that meant
Hillary could lose to him but she could
lose to him right it wouldn't be him
winning it would be her losing and
that's actually what happened well now
Hillary is doing the rounds and it is
amazing I mean the reason that she lost
is the reason why she's doing the rounds
John McCain's in write a book after he
lost MIT Romney didn't write a book
after he lost
hey John Kerry didn't really write a
book after he lost all these people sort
of disappeared they sort of went away
they went away because they knew that
they were doing more damage to their
party by sticking around than they would
by by actually than by just disappearing
Hillary is sticking around because she
cannot get over the fact that she lost
she has to wake up in the morning and
look at the mirror and say to herself
what in the hell just happened here and
that's of course the name of her book so
she does this interview and she starts
off by saying she's not gonna run for
office again like yeah we know you lost
is your political career over yes as an
active politician it's over you will
never be a cannibal I'm for I am done
with being a candidate but I am not done
with politics because I literally
believe that our country's future is at
stake you represent me so she says that
she's not gonna run for office again in
any case that is not a giant shock that
not gonna run for office because again
she lost then she admits that she hadn't
drafted a concession speech this shows
you why Donald Trump won and it shows
why Republicans can continue to win no
matter how incompetent they are
Democrats are so confident that the
world is just gonna fall into their labs
that they don't even seem to be making
an effort Hillary was a good example of
this here she is explaining that she
hadn't even drafted a concession speech
you know I just kind of went in the
bedroom laid down on the bed just
thought okay I just have to wait this
out but then midnight I decided well you
know looks like it's not going to work I
had not drafted a concession speech a
victory speech our best days are still
ahead of us you remember it but she
never thought that she was gonna lose
and then what becomes clear is that she
has never given up on her line the line
is that everyone who voted against her
was a white nationalist supremacist
piece of garbage this is her line and
this is what Democrats still believe so
long as Democrats believe this they're
going to lose the fact is a lot of
people who did not vote for her people
like me right a lot of us were just
appalled by the alt-right a lot of us
were appalled by white supremacism a lot
of people who voted for Donald Trump are
appalled by white supremacism they just
didn't like her but Hillary continues to
double down on this line and it's one of
the reasons why there is this backlash
that has been soft toward the all right
because the more that Hillary Clinton
says that everybody's a white
supremacist the more that people say
well I'm not a white supremacist maybe
those actual white supremacists over
there aren't white supremacist either
here's Hillary Clinton doubling down on
the deplorable and pretend you remember
she have a speech in the middle of the
campaign in which she suggested that
everyone who is supporting Donald Trump
was a deplorable white supremacist she
read a bunch of headlines from Breitbart
she talked about the all right and then
she linked everybody on the right with
the alt-right and everybody on the right
picked up on that and they said well I'm
not a deplorable and if she's gonna call
me a deplorable then I'll call myself a
deplorable and she still doesn't
understand that was a galvanizing moment
for the opposition to her why do you
think that word deplorable had been
circulating in your mind well I thought
Trump was behaving in a deplorable
manner I thought a lot of his appeals to
voters were deplorable
I thought his behavior as we saw on the
Access Hollywood tape what
deplorable and there were a large number
of people who didn't care it did not
matter to them okay maybe it mattered to
them then they looked at you and they
said well I'm not voting for that lady
right that that seems to me more likely
but again she can't get over herself she
still think she was wildly popular
except for the sneaking Nazis right
those thieving sneaking Nazis and
Russians it was the new Molotov
Ribbentrop pact and they decided that
Ribbentrop pact and they they put
together this alliance against Hillary
Clinton personally and then she
continues along these lines right she
still can't get over and she says that
Trump's inauguration speech was a cry
from the white nationalist good on the
platform you know feeling just like an
out-of-body experience and then his
speech which was a cry from the white
nationalist gut okay it was not a speech
that was a cry from the white
nationalist got his speech his
inauguration speech was I thought quite
well written I thought it was very dark
but I thought that it was effective I
don't think was about white nationalism
so much as it was about the idea that
America had fallen on hard times and now
Trump was gonna raise us up again right
Trump was going to be the guy who
dragged us out of that crevasse the
reason all of this matters the reason
Hillary Clinton still matters is because
her spirit still infuses the Democratic
Party her cackling spirit still infuses
the Democratic Party they don't
understand why they lost they think that
they are just going to kind of sweep in
to victory again on the basis of
confusion and ire and anger and hatred
for the other side and I don't think
that that's right and you can see that
what what's happened here is is we now
have reactionaries on both sides so
Hillary Clinton is a reactionary of the
left she thinks that everybody on the
right is white nationalist then you have
reactionaries on the right who people
like Steve Ben and I think who have
turns Hillary Clinton said okay well if
you're gonna react that way then I'm
gonna look at the all right and I'm not
gonna consider these people the worst
things in the world I'm gonna make room
for them you know maybe they'll they'll
come out in the wash eventually I'm
gonna talk about Steve ban in 60 minutes
interview in a minute I don't think
Steve is a white nationalist by any
means I mean I noticed II pretty well I
was on a phone call with him for
basically two hours a day for two years
of my life so I know Steve pretty well
but I do think that Steve fell into a
trap that a lot of the right is for
into but again the left is pushing the
right into this trap and the right
should be careful not to fall into it
another example of this it's not just
Hillary Clinton who believes this
Stephen Colbert he was on his show the
other night and he actually gave a Nazi
salute because his suggestion was that
Donald Trump and Steve Bannon were
actual Nazis and then he throws up a
Nazi salute after the Charlottesville
situation I told John Kelly I was the
only guy that came out and tried to
defend him I was only a guy that said
he's talking about something taking it
up to a higher level he's definitely
taking it to a higher level I'd say his
support is about about up there right
around here
[Applause]
okay and say there he is giving the Nazi
salute is though Dannan and Trump are
Nazis and then the right goes well we're
gonna call them Nazis I mean then
everybody's a Nazi Nazism must not exist
this is the mistake the left makes and
it's really stupid it's really stupid
but the right has to be careful not to
fall into the same mistake now I want to
talk about Bannon because I think the
bannon's interview on 60 minutes was
less important for who Bannon is and it
was more important for what Bannon hopes
to represent and why the Trump movement
is I think a Trebek ibly split and I
don't think it's likely to cohere I'm
gonna explain why in just a second for
that I'm gonna have to go over to Daley
wired.com and become a subscriber for
$9.99 a month you can become a
subscriber over at daily wire.com that
means you get the rest of my show live
you get Andrew Clavin show live which
starts at 10:30 Pacific time you get
michael Knowles's show live which starts
at 12:30 Pacific time all of them great
shows get to watch them live on video
because this isn't just an audio show
plus you also got to be part of all of
our mailbag and when we post the shows
later then you get to watch them without
ads if you want to get all of those plus
the add the website without any ads at
all and if you want to get this
magnificent tumbler then all you have to
do is spend $99 a year just get the
annual subscription you can pay more
than that for the monthly get the annual
and then you will be guaranteed to get
all of those things Plus this fantastic
leftist here's hot or cold tumblr
everyone envies this tumblr I won't say
names like steven crowder but everyone
MV envies these particular mugs they say
they're the greatest mugs that have ever
been created I can vouch for that
although I have not tried every mug I
can tell you that in Indiana Jones and
the Last Crusade
when someone chose not this mug it ended
very poorly for him so this is the kind
of tumbler that you should use so $99
gets you the annual subscription or go
over later to iTunes or SoundCloud
please go over to youtube by the way and
subscribe to the daily water channel as
well that allows us to continue bringing
you content and it allows you to see as
much of the content as humanly possible
as soon as humanly possible over at
YouTube so go check that out we are the
largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
okay so last night former White House
chief strategist and former campaign
chief strategist Steve Bannon was on 60
minutes now as I say I know Steve pretty
well I'm not a fan of Steve bannon's I
think personally he is he's not a nice
guy or the person but Steve's an
interesting figure he for sure an
interesting figure and Steve's
appearance on 60 minutes is less
interesting for who he is and for what
he was in the Trump administration than
for what he represents which is a sort
of attempt to meld the it of the Trump
with the super-ego of the Trump it's an
attempt to create a Trump movement the
biggest problem with Trump so far and
the biggest problem with Trump overall
is that Trump actually is just an empty
vessel Trump does not have an ideology
Trump does not have a philosophy it's
why he's happy to make deals with
Democrats he's a quote/unquote pragmatic
deal maker just a guy who will go out
and make deals with anyone and you see
people like Steve trying to give him a
patina of intellectual coherence as
though there's a natural philosophy
behind what Trump does rather than a
series of impulses this doesn't mean all
his impulses are bad President Trump it
just means that trying to create a
philosophy around Trump is sort of like
trying to tap water to the wall it's
just not going to work
you know Trump does not have any
substance to him that you can actually
tack to the wall and you can see
bannon's difficulty in doing this so
first I want to say that you know all of
the media's attention on Bandhan is
wildly overblown and an attempt by the
media to pretend that Trump isn't
president that's really what's going on
here with Steve okay Steve
joined the campaign he was not by any
stretch of the imagination the key
figure in the Trump campaign Trump was
always the key figure in the Trump
campaign I think he was able to impose a
little bit of discipline on Trump during
the campaign and did a good job with
that in a way that some other people
couldn't he was kind of the Trump
Whisperer for a little while but the
fact is that that Bannon himself was
never particularly important either to
the Trump campaign or to the Trump
administration right by the end of the
administration by the time end of his
time in the administration he basically
been marginalized to a small office
where he had a white board full of
Trump's promises that hadn't been kept
where he would obsessively read the
newspapers in the Internet and then call
presumably Matthew Boyle over a
Breitbart to talk about it the fact is
Steve was not a major figure by the end
of the Trump administration his time the
Trump administration he'd been
marginalized every report says this he
did not leave because he was so vital in
fact he was so non vital that there's
still his slots
has not been filled they literally made
up a position for him gave him the
position and then didn't fill the
position when he was gone he also
happens to be the money connection for
Trump he's very much connected to the
Mercer's who are a very wealthy family
down in Florida who funded Trump and are
funding a trump super PAC the reason
that Bannon is sort of important as a
general mood is because now Bannon is
saying that he's going to attempt to
lead a bunch of primaries against
sitting Republican senators who don't
back Trump now the only reason that he
can get away with this is because of
this split inside the mentality with
regard to Trump one people really like
Trump and they want to back from two
Trump doesn't really have an agenda so
even people who voted with Trump on key
issues like Jeff Flake in Arizona right
Jeff Blake could be primary why because
he said nasty things about Trump and
then you see people on the Democrat side
who didn't vote with Trump like Heidi
Heitkamp and you're not seeing a lot of
talk from the Republicans about how
they're gonna take down Heitkamp Trump
just went out and praised her so it's
very incoherent it's very
discombobulated the reason I say that
that Bannon is not such an important
figure in that the media are making him
an important figure is because the media
do not want to it's another way for the
media not to accept that Trump is
president right Trump isn't president an
ins president i Trump isn't president
John Kelly's President Trump isn't
president Reince Priebus is president
some people on the right used to do this
with Obama some of us on the right used
to do this oh it's really Valerie
Jarrett whispering into his ear it's
really Rahm Emmanuel whispering into his
ear the left dinner with Karl Rove Karl
Rove is whispering into bushes ear the
fact is the president is the president
he's one who makes the calls it was
Trump who decided that he did not trust
Bandhan enough it was Trump who
marginalised and this is why Bandhan
giving this excuse here about seer
Bandon give an excuse for why he's no
longer at the White House and it just
doesn't fly here he says he was not cut
out to be a staffer to be this strong a
defender why aren't you there why and
with the president of the states who you
applauded so loudly have allowed you to
leave if he didn't want you out Knossos
act opposite I was a I was a standing
look I'm not cut out to be a staffer and
the one in the one in the White House in
the way
your title was not Stafford that was
your title was chief strategist staffer
I was a federal government employee
there's certain things you can't do I
cannot take the fight do we have to take
the fight too when I'm an adviser to the
president for government boy you can't
do it okay that's that's a that's not
really why he left
okay he's already achieved the height of
his power you have to understand
something about Steve personally to
understand why he's not super an
important figure and that is that Steve
basically lucked into every job that
he's held for the last ten years he sort
of latched on to various figures he
latched on to Michelle Bachmann and then
he latched on to Dick Morris and then he
latched on to Sarah Palin and then he
latched on to Andrew Breitbart he was
there when Andrew died that allowed him
to get his foot in the door in terms of
using editorial a Breitbart to push for
Trump and then he latched on to Trump
and Trump won right that's wrote Bannon
is not a force in his own right he's not
a mover and shaker Bannon is more of a
barnacle on whatever powerful figure he
happens to follow but here's the part
that I want to talk about Bannon right
like why am I wasting the time if I
really think he's not that important why
am I wasting the time on him I do think
that he is important as a window into
the mentality of what some members of
the media are trying to do with Trump or
Trump supporters and that is they're
trying to fuse the in with the super-ego
so in the Freudian analysis your
personality is made up of three parts
okay this is this is basic Freud you're
it which is your series of instincts
right you want to have sex you want to
have it you want to eat steak right
you're it is driving you to do these
emotional things then there's your
super-ego your super-ego is the
Apollonian part of you and then the sort
of Nietzsche and construct it's the part
of your brain that that says I will use
rationality and logic to check the it
and make deals with the aid that's the
super-ego and then there's the ego that
militates between them right then
there's the ego that decides okay that's
you right the ego is you and the and the
ego is what two sides have I gotta
follow the the it or am I gonna follow
the super-ego and a little too basic to
that sort of the breakdown so what's
happened with Trump film is that Trump
is largely driven by his in there's been
an attempt to intellectualize Trump
right there was something called the
Journal of American greatness which
attempts to intellectualize Trump there
are some intellectuals like Victor Davis
Hanson who have tried to create a
philosophy around Trump benen sort of
tried to create a philosophy around
Trump but Bannon is posing himself as
the ego of trumpism
that he is going to do the hard work of
trying to bring together the
philosophical strain of trumpism and
of Trump and so in order to do that
sometimes he has to be the it and
sometimes he has to be the super-ego he
thinks this is what Breitbart is going
to be he thinks this is what all of
these candidates that he's going to use
two primary all these other Republican
figures are going to be the new movement
is going to be a merger it's going to be
a philosophy of trumpism that Trump may
not at all times believe but the soul of
Trump that a fighting soul of Trump
right this is sort of what he wants to
create beautiful vision except that
Trump will not be bound by a philosophy
Trump is militantly anti philosophy from
his militantly anti ideology he doesn't
like any of these things any boundaries
on him make him angry
okay Trump is unbridled it in politics
so you'll see Bandhan trying to do this
right it was almost a dichotomous
interview with 60 minutes and you see
this from a lot of Trump supporters that
half the time it's Trump's the edge
fight fight fight and then half the time
it's well he's playing 40 chess it's not
really that he's not fighting it's not
knee-jerk it's not angry he's just he's
playing super sophisticated chess and
I've suggested all along that most of
what he does cannot be explained by
strategy it's more explained by by the
in your naseeb Anand do this routine
here and I think that it's telling so
here is Bannon going after Charlie Rose
with regard to Ryan and McConnell so he
says we're gonna go after Paul Ryan
we're gonna go after Mitch McConnell
this is the it'd part of the Trump world
the Republican establishment is trying
to nullify the 2016 election that's a
brutal fact we have to face the
Republican establishment like an
establishment wants to nullify the 2016
trying to nullify the 2016 election
absolutely okay so it's Ryan McConnell
Franken albeit Rakhal onto the 2016
election we have to fight them at every
turn
fight fight fight fight fight fight
fight right this is the in part of it
first of all from what I've seen Paul
Ryan is not trying to nullify the
effects of the 2016 election he's been
basically walking around with his lips
puckered to Trump's ass since the
election started or since the at least
since the election was completed so the
the idea that Ryan and McConnell are
desperately trying to undermine Trump
you know I don't think that's right I
think that Bannon is mad because their
agenda is not his agenda and sometimes
Trump seemed to follow their agenda but
the idea here is that Trump is the it
and Bandhan is the it - he's the fighter
in the trenches don't you understand and
then at the same time you'll see ban and
say things like you know I wish the
Trump had used more strategy when I came
- for example daca right he Benin openly
said that he he opposed Trump getting
rid of daca actually which is an amazing
thing Breitbart I was there okay
Breitbart was the most anti daca outlet
that was that was present in American
politics I'm worried about losing the
house now because this up because of
daca in my fear is that with this six
months downrange
if we have another huge if this goes all
the way down to its logical conclusion
in February and March it will be a civil
war inside the Republican Party that
will be every bit as vitriolic as 2013
and to me his fear is the civil war but
he just said he wanted a civil war
wrecked he just said once that gonna go
I want a civil war with Ryan and with
McConnell but my great fear is a civil
war that will bleed down into 2018 over
daca so which is it
is he the it or is he the super-ego and
the answer is these two things cannot
coexist because again they don't exist
in a single person okay the it'd the
super-ego they don't exist in movements
they don't exist in movements
okay the movement either has to be
driven by the it or it has to be driven
by the super-ego or that you have to
work hand in hand but you cannot have a
movement that is split between it and
super-ego and the it pays no attention
to the super ego and the super ego pay
no pays no attention to the it'd unless
the central figure is Trump right unless
Trump is the ego
Bannen cannot be Trump's ego Bannen
cannot be the guy who stands there and
militates between the in and super-ego
if Trump is the it'd and Paul Ryan is
the super-ego bannin cannot be the eagle
because baman is not that important and
herein lies the problem for Bannon and
for the movement generally for trumpism
Trump is not a guy who is pulling from
the ID's sometimes and from the
super-ego sometimes he is pulling only
from the in the it'd is this
administration the super-ego doesn't
even exist again you as a person have
all three of these qualities a movement
can only have all three of these
qualities its super-ego and ego if the
ego is the guy at the center of it
Ronald Reagan could be the ego he could
militate between the the rabid part of
his base and the super-ego highly
intellectualized portion of his base
right George W Bush could do that
because he was more of a judgement guy
Trump is not a judgement guy and Bannon
can't be that for him and Bannon trying
to be the ego inevitably is going to put
him at odds with Trump he's going to try
his best not to do that but that's what
it's going to be
or he's just gonna have to give in to
Trump's head right or he's just gonna
have to give in to Trump's head and
surrender the super-ego part of this
entire argument and that'll be
fascinating and remember for all this
talk about how much power abandoned in
Breitbart wield in these election cycles
I mean I was there when they tried to
basically primary Paul Ryan with Paul
endale and and Nalin got killed by 70
points so you know the only race I'm
aware Breitbart had any impact in at all
which again I think Breitbart when I was
working there was a very powerful sight
and did some good things but and and I
think they still do some good things but
I think that the idea that that
Breitbart had a market impact on
election cycles outside of you know
Trump which is a huge one obviously and
the primaries which were enormous and
Dave brat I think is a mistake they're
gonna go around primary and all these
candidates and be successful in that I
think that's probably a little bit a
little bit much
okay so again you can sort of see this
split between the the it and the
super-ego when you look at people like
for example Jeanine Pirro and Jim Jordan
so Jeanine Pirro is definitely a
representative of the trumpian ed and
she is obviously an foxnews she'll says
a radio show and here she was talking
about how Trump making in the old
Democrats last week was a great great
great thing right this is the in portion
of the movement the establishment is out
to get Donald Trump they say nice things
because they don't want to really be
outed but when I saw Donald Trump this
week decide that he was going to cut a
deal with Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
certainly you know not people that die
admire for sure but I can't blame him
and I said good for him not only is he
gonna shake up the establishment these
he's gonna change the paradigm you know
good for him good for him why why good
for him because I can't blame him this
is the words that you hear out of
people's mouths when they're defending
the trumpian it I can't blame him he
doesn't deserve blame sort of like
you're dealing with a small child or a
dog I can't blame him sure he bit me but
I mean I did smell like bacon you know
the this this notion is is not really it
doesn't indicate the strength of a
movement again it's it indicates that
this split Trump because he's such an
adjuvant candidate he has opened up this
gap between it and super-ego in the
movement that I'm not sure can be
rectified again unless there's a new
leader
of the movement which may come along
sometime in the future but until then
we're just gonna have to suffer through
the split okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like I'm in the middle of
this book that is really fantastically
written I really am enjoying it Edward
feasor
the book is the last superstition a
refutation of the New Atheism so he
takes on Richard Dawkins and Daniel
Dennett and he talks about how a lot of
the arguments in favor of atheism are
basically taking arguments made by
Aristotle and Plato and Thomas Aquinas
and dumbing them down and then refuting
the dumbed down right then creating a
straw man and then burning it and this
is a much more sophisticated defense of
the Aristotelian defense of God right
that the first cause the unmoved mover
it's it's it's really quite fascinating
it makes a very rational case for the
notion of an unmoved mover in the
universe and explains why that is not
easily refuted simply by saying well why
can't there be a mover of the unmoved
mover that the whole book is about why
that's not true and it's it's quite good
it's colorfully written and rare for a
philosophy book it's really readable and
lucid you know there there's a lot of
lot I mentioned this last couple weeks
when I've been talking a lot of
philosophy there's a lot of philosophy
that is really poorly written I mean try
to read a page of can't it's just it's
written in gobbledygook it's it's almost
impossible to understand some like
Aristotle and Plato are actually pretty
readable the the John Locke is is pretty
readable but a lot of philosophers are
really not readable and they read like
garbage and that is not the case with
ever and feasor the book is the last
superstition or refutation of the New
Atheism and I think it has a lot of
important insights and interesting
things to say okay however other things
that I like so I'm Betsy DeVos as I
mentioned the Secretary of Education
last week she came out and she got rid
of the what they called Dear Colleague
letter put out by the Obama
administration in 2011 and this was a
letter that basically said that colleges
were no longer allowed to kick over
sexual harassment sexual abuse
allegations to the police instead they
had to create up these kangaroo courts
she says this is nonsense and she's
exactly right any perceived offense can
become a full-blown title 9
investigation but if everything is
harassment then nothing is punishing
speech protected by the First Amendment
trivializes actual harassment
it teaches students the wrong lesson
about the importance of free speech in
our democracy harassment codes which
trample speech rights derail the primary
mission of a school to pursue truth good
for her
okay what she is saying here is exactly
right and I understand that there are a
lot of people who are wary that that
schools are gonna quash allegations of
sexual harassment well that's why we
have a police force I'm sorry to say
that we don't we can't do any better
than that we can't we can't do any
better than if something bad happens you
have to go report it to the authorities
and the authorities have to have some
sort of evidentiary showing in order to
prosecute people otherwise this turns
very quickly into Stalinist show trials
and that's not just accusations of even
if something bad happened if you don't
have evidence to prove that it happened
or a country where innocence is still
required before we call somebody guilty
okay
time for one more you know let's do one
more thing that I like this is really
funny so Michael Moore demanded that
mar-a-lago be used as a as a hurricane
shelter he said has he opened up
mar-a-lago as a shelter he had 56,000
likes okay and then Donald Trump jr.
shellacked him because Donald Trump jr.
pointed out um dude we're actually in
the hurricane zone we had to evacuate it
so it's amazing how the left will jump
on any talking point that's anti Trump
in order to push against him without
looking at you know actual logic or
facts okay time for some things I hate
let's do it
all righty so a couple of things that I
hate first of all the media have been
making complete fools of themselves they
go out in the middle of the hurricane
and they stand out there by getting
blown over by wind and I understand that
this is like amusing to all of us I
understand that we are all sort of
hoping that that eventually Chris Cuomo
be standing out there and then he'll
just go flying 100 feet now that'll get
hurt but then he'll like go flying 100
feet ago disappear into the waves for
just a second before a helicopter picks
him up for the same reason we watched
the wall in DES try to walk across the
Grand Canyon ie you want to be there in
case they fall you sort of want to watch
the coverage of these hurricanes here's
some more on getting out of his car and
then trying to demonstrate how strong
the winds are in hurricane Irma
and there the city goes he was standing
there trying to stand up to be titled
worst hurricane and he's and he's
full-on pushing against the hurricane
and you got to admit when you watch this
you're sort of hoping that he just sort
of go sailing off the screen because
when people do stupid things then you
sort of hope that they they pay a
particular penalty not a harsh physical
penalty you wouldn't want anything
terrible to happen of the guy but I
would like to see him get knocked on his
butt a little bit cuz it is it is
ridiculous like don't be a people
please please okay other things that I
hate so President Trump was praising the
coast guard and he was talking about
what a great job they did wonderful I
wish that President Trump his first
instinct were not always to to deal with
things in terms of fame and fortune but
that's just how he deals with stuff
here's President Trump praising the
coast guard if you talk about branding
no brand has improved more than the
United States goes okay
no no improved its brand was the Coast
Guard having serious branding problems
yeah what were they being boycotted like
I'm just wondering how that work was
look we're like Philip Morris they're
putting out commercials for children and
then they were banned by the federal
government mr. president please get the
marketing side of yourself under control
it's not a big thing like really this
small ask but can you please stop seeing
things in terms of how you see them I
understand that Trump thinks of himself
as a brand or because he is he's one of
the world's great he's he is I think
probably the greatest Brander in history
I mean the guy branded himself to the
presidency of the United States but the
Coast Guard really did not need to
improve its brand like let's just cut
that out if we can okay so we will be
back here tomorrow I'll give you the
update on Berkeley I will talk about an
TFI ante people went nuts in Portland
yesterday they attacked a bunch of cops
obviously my fault and we'll bring you
the latest on the political situation as
we always do I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
you